[Applause]
how much energy is there in empty space
we believe there is 10 to the minus 8
herbs in every cubic centimeter of empty
space how much was in the ERG it's a
very small amount you know if a mosquito
flaps its wings or a fly I guess flaps
its wings it's about one earns worth of
energy so work is not very much we're
talking about a hundred millionth of an
ERG in every cubic centimeter of space
now it might seem strange that
completely empty space contains energy
but there are two good reasons why
scientists think this is the case one is
because the expansion of the universe is
speeding up and that's thought to be
caused by dark energy which fills all
space and makes gravity repulsive
we always think the gravity always pulls
but according to Einstein the way
gravity works really depends on the
material itself and energy tied to space
gravity pushes it doesn't pull if that
number is ten to the minus eight thirds
for cubic centimeter then you fit the
data and that's the dark energy it makes
the universe accelerate its constant
does everything you want the second
reason why empty space contains energy
is because it isn't really empty there
is the idea that thanks to quantum
mechanics we do expect particles to come
in and out of existence and so space is
full of energy
yeah there's there was nothing there
when we first looked nothing there when
we later looked could we say for sure if
we had looked in the middle that there
weren't particles there no there might
have been evidence for these so-called
virtual particles who came from studying
the light emitted by energized hydrogen
atoms Niels Bohr first used the
particular colors of light to devise his
quantum model of the atom where the
electron orbits the nucleus in certain
allowed orbits each with its own
specific energy when the electron jumps
from a higher energy orbit to a lower
one it gives off light and the energy
and hence color of that light is
determined by the energy difference
between the two levels as quantum theory
developed Bohr's orbits were superseded
by probabilistic electron clouds but the
energy levels remained mostly unchanged
then in 1947 Willis lamb and his grad
student Robert Rutherford attempted to
test the best version of quantum theory
at the time which was the Dirac equation
and they did this by measuring the
energy levels in hydrogen
more precisely than ever before now what
they found did not match up with the
theory one of the energy levels was
actually not one but rather two very
closely spaced energy levels and this is
known as the lamb shift
they used microwaves to excite the
electron between these two levels so why
were there two energy levels where there
was supposed to be just one well the
answer is virtual particles for example
around the proton virtual electron
positron pairs pop in and out of
existence this is permitted by the laws
of quantum mechanics so long as they
don't stick around for too long during
their brief lives the negative electron
is attracted to the positive proton
while the positron is repelled away from
it
this means the charge of the proton is
shielded by the virtual electrons
surrounding it this affects the energy
of the 2's orbital in which the electron
is closer to the nucleus differently
from the 2p orbital and that's what
causes the energy levels to split and
this is just one contribution to the
energy difference the full calculation
involves drawing a series of Fineman
diagrams that show all the possible
interactions between real and virtual
particles and adding up the contribution
from each one and there's an infinite
chain of these different diagrams so you
might worry that you can predict nothing
at all but you need to add up an
infinite number of numbers to get the
right answer but the point is that every
time you have these two vertices these
two places where the photon hits the
electron that's associated with a number
alpha the fine-structure constant which
is 1 over 137 which is a small number so
this leading term this classical
contribution is already small and these
more complicated ones you notice there
are more vertices appear and there
diagrams get more and more complicated
there are more and more of these terms
so you get alpha squared alpha cubed
alper to the fourth and the numbers
become smaller and smaller and smaller
so the more complicated diagrams the
more intricate effects of the virtual
particles become less and less important
using the Dirac equation but adding in
the effects of virtual electrons
positrons and photons we can actually
calculate the values of atomic Bram
with better accuracy than one part in a
billion that is incredible in fact
physicist Lawrence Krauss calls it the
best and most accurate prediction in all
of science so with the spectacular
usefulness of virtual particles you
think it would be pretty hard for anyone
to doubt their existence but then again
they have never been directly observed
in fact theoretically that's impossible
explain virtual particles is is always
tricky because it's very hard to think
of them in any sort of real way they can
go in the opposite direction of their
momenta and and do these things which
are not consistent with with a real
particle so virtual particles have a
strange sort of existence where they're
indispensable for calculations obviously
but you can never directly observe them
but maybe this is not actually a real
problem it's just the result of thinking
about reality in the wrong way maybe as
the fundamental building blocks of our
universe we shouldn't be talking about
particles at all but rather fields the
truth is the quantum field theory is
according to our best current modern
understanding the right way to talk
about nature at a fundamental level when
we talk about particle physics we talk
about electrons and gluons and quarks to
the modern physicist these are all
vibrations and fields in exactly the
same way that the photon is a vibration
in the electromagnetic field just like
there's an electromagnetic field there's
also an electron field there's a
neutrino field there's an up quark field
and a top quark field etc and these
fields fill space and usually they're
sitting there fairly quietly but when
they vibrate and you look at it you see
that in terms of individual particles in
this picture virtual particles are
quantum fluctuations little disturbances
in the field they play a role in
interactions but they aren't measurable
as real particles themselves and since
they exist everywhere they should imbue
the vacuum with energy if you were to
try to estimate the amount of energy due
to the virtual particles in empty space
what kind of number do you get for the
energy of empty space yeah this is a
huge problem because the back of the end
estimates says there should be about 10
to the 112 herbs for every cubic
centimeter compared to the 10 to the
minus 8 that we actually get in other
words you predict 10 to the 120 times
the energy density of empty space that
you actually observe so obviously your
back-of-the-envelope calculation is
wildly wildly incorrect and no one is
really quite sure why the way we see the
universe responding to the cosmological
constant the way we expect the vacu to
behave are the most discrepant things
that we have in physics if they are the
same thing how is it possible that both
the best and the worst prediction in
science are both based on the same
underlying physics of virtual particles
I mean one experiment seems to show that
the theory is perfectly correct
while another shows that we could not be
more wrong you know there are a lot of
areas of human endeavor where we fear
being so wildly incorrect but in science
this discrepancy is actually really
exciting because it shows us a piece of
the puzzle that we haven't figured out
just yet that we have to solve this
problem if we are to fully understand
the universe and in that way this is the
best clue we have at the work that still
needs to be done so yeah we don't know
but that's always good it's always good
to say you don't know right hey this
episode of veritasium was supported by
viewers like you on patreon and by the
great courses Plus which is an awesome
online learning platform with thousands
of video courses in all different areas
including one I'm particularly excited
about which is on the Higgs boson taught
by my friend Sean Carroll who you saw
featured in this video now in it he
actually dedicates one whole lecture to
field theory so if you want to go deeper
into the things I was talking about here
then you want to check out his course
and you can actually watch his whole
course and all the others for free for a
one month free trial by going to the
great courses plus comm slash veritasium
or just click the link in the
description so I really want to thank
the great courses plus for supporting me
and I want to thank you for watching